Oh what is going on you little crusty
ass butthole yes funny FATF it did take
a hiatus last week but you know I'm back
in it right now as you can see the hair
is growing longer because I did not lose
that 20 pounds yet nope mm people have
been telling me I kind of look like
Glenn from Walking Dead you know if he
was retired and he had nothing to look
forward to but it's been an interesting
journey but I know that a lot of you out
there have reached something that I have
reached which is the plateau now what is
a plateau you guys ask in terms of
working out a plateau is basically where
you have a lot of trouble losing your
weight because you know it just starts
to get a little more difficult at a
certain point now personally I have
reached my plateau where I have been in
this about a couple of months now and I
haven't lost as much weight as I've lost
in the first month now how do I feel
about that you ask it [ __ ] pictures
become oh yes it does but nobody here
working my [ __ ] ass off and I've lost
only about 5 pounds in the last couple
weeks you know what you still progress
but you know I want to cut this [ __ ]
hair I'm over here looking like I own a
Korean market you join your [ __ ]
I don't like this hair okay you know
what happens when you have hair like
this people automatically assume that
you're [ __ ] smart I'm not coming up
to me ask me to do your [ __ ] math
homework a [ __ ] what's wrong with you
excuse me so what's the cosine of this
number cosine cosine another for you
[ __ ] let you [ __ ] that's not what you
meant is it now I have been asking a lot
of other people who have reached this
part and basically what they've been
telling me is that I need to switch it
up I didn't switch up my workouts that's
so much maybe the intensity but the
types of workouts that I'm doing because
now my body has adjusted to the pain
that I'd be giving that person that [ __ ]
doesn't make sense to me cuz I am always
in pain I hate when your [ __ ] biceps
a sort of [ __ ] and you just look like a
velociraptor all day what's up baby what
though man get stressed out a [ __ ] you
ever tried to touch your own dick when
you buy some story you just let it hang
there just leave it daily huh that's
right I'm just kidding I don't I just
yes I do everything every guy does every
now and then no no you don't but for
those of you out there who are asking
what type of workouts that I'm doing I
started up powerlifting with Bart now
the problem with me and powerlifting is
that I have a lot of old injuries I can
go on a list about how injured I am and
you would sit here for 16 days wanting
to kill me that's right and this is
why I want to stress to you guys not to
worry so much about what somebody else
is doing because their body is not your
body you got to understand what works
for you and not so much what works for
them now what I've come to the
realization is that my body is a [ __ ]
Pinto see my body you got a [ __ ] real
flag dangle it to make you work a
certain way you got a stick the car in
the key hit the AC pump the brake a
couple of times hit the ebrake smack the
window and bam you get it going my
body's a piece of [ __ ] but I think I'm
starting to figure out what I can do and
what's a little bit more important for
me diet has always been a lot more
important than the actual workouts even
though I didn't want my strength gold I
don't think that's gonna happen as of
now just because I you know I've been
going to the dog that he's becoming
what's wrong with me and it's basically
everything my body it's like it's like I
ate a dynamite and it just exploded
everything it's like and you know what's
even worse than this head do you guys
notice that when you started eating
healthier your farts started spilling
ten times worse what the [ __ ] is with
healthy farms I'm not even kidding you
yesterday I thought of something so
nasty I turned around and a tree just
died you said what's up my fart so bad
ass come bleep in you said [ __ ] you but
in fact I just farted right now smell
let somebody [ __ ] directly on this floor
but yes buddy fat fit make sure that you
guys keep it up and if you have
plateaued you got to switch it up you
got to switch out two workouts and try
something new
and trust me workouts after a while do
get boring so flipping it up just might
not be a bad idea just don't be
discouraged keep on going because if you
get discharged guess what I'm
discouraged - they sure - I don't want
to [ __ ] win it you know why wearing
it is because I [ __ ] forgot to do
laundry so I have to wear normal clothes
like a decent human being I don't want
to do this guess what though still like
winter pants that's right look at the
[ __ ] still is you see this - this best
ass right there
death ass booty booty booty yes buddy
fat v we aren't back and do you like
this shirt I don't know it makes me feel
uncomfortable call me but this week is
gonna be a very interesting week for me
because I am switching up my diet to the
max and I'm talking about way different
a lot more raw foods a lot more
healthier stuff uncooked no oils no
process you should like that it's just
something I'm trying out I don't know
just give me the dough I got a little
bit tired of my previous diet so I'm
just trying it out give it a go you
don't even know what you dislike or like
until you try it
that's right try and dick sometimes
remember if you guys love the shirts
that I was wearing before some of the
sweaters the hats of [ __ ]
that you already know where you can get
that at go-for-broke apparel calm that's
what we do that's how we doing it holla
holla holla holla
but anyways funny fat fit remember life
is always what you may be but it's up to
you to take what you deserve let's go
for broke trail off your epithet that
now what is a plateau you guys know what
is that yeah